it's time for screen junkies movie
fights today's episode is brought to you
by blue apron huh what's going on guys
we're doing it is our grand reopening
two movie fights guess what three
fighters three chick four chairs because
I'm in a chair oh let's take a look at
all this goodness I was on a Star Trek
oh you guys I am so pumped uh welcome
back we're excited to be back with this
format you asked for it we didn't want
to do it but now very very exciting and
we got a kick-ass crew of folks movie
lovers to open it up with Oh first he's
a good friend of the family super funny
comedian you know from the Schmo down
Joshua kugel thanks for having me man
hell yeah I'm excited my first movie
fights obviously I've been on TV fights
a few times but I couldn't have picked a
better group of dudes that hang out with
and yell about movies heck yeah Josh
thanks for being here thanks um oh this
mother father is one of the writers on
honest trailers he's a super funny dude
an all-around great guy
Joestar thanks for being here hey thanks
how look I want to welcome Josh cuz it's
your first like proper movie fight
there's a lot of pressure on me right
now yeah you know I stink guy from Dan
Merle over there
want you to feel more at home and I know
that you're from the Schmo down where
they talk trash a lot so I downloaded
all these Pittsburgh Penguins jokes from
jokes for us what do the Pittsburgh
Penguins and the Titanic have in common
they both look good until they hit the
ice Mario Lemieux was on the time
getting the light
what do you call 23 millionaires are
around a TV watching the Stanley Cup
Finals the Pittsburgh Penguins I mean I
don't know I feel right at home last but
not least from the nerd goat podcast
welcome back our friend at Greer this is
fun I'm happy I'm happy to be part of
this relaunch the relaunch yeah it's
like being part of the new 52 the next
reinvention of the Fantastic Four like
it went Alba yeah then you have that one
we saw with Michael B Jordan and now now
this is your Fantastic Four there's like
three or four people in there we don't
give a yeah I agree with all of
these comments yeah so FYI the show
works thusly
after each argument they're going to be
three judges weighing in I'm one of the
judges and let's meet the other judges
shall we the Dan cam first off he is our
resident fact checker and all-around
swell guy
you know you love Mr Dan Moreau looking
in the face oh yeah we have a direct
line yes good I like it it's a good eye
line yeah very good how are you feeling
how you feeling about the new setup I
mean they say you can't go home again
we had some sage in here earlier we had
a whole ceremony yeah oh yeah no I
chopped a chicken's head off
better feeling good and yeah look at
this here we are we're back the old
table you can tell us the old table
because it hasn't been dusted there's a
layer of dust which is unfortunate for
variety
it's fighter skimmer and sitting next to
Dan she is the voice of the people
Daniel Radford great to have you on yes
i'ii be the social media ambassador so
don't forget to tweet me them sick sick
memes you can you can directly tweet me
or you can do it movie fight it's live i
am checking both and the way that it
works from my judging is that for the
first three rounds i am the voice of you
and so what you're gonna do is you're
gonna vote youtube only i know some
people do some fun Twitter polls and
those are great but those don't count
ours are only on youtube and so what you
want to do is if you don't know how to
access the little iCard thingy first of
all you don't have to worry about
refreshing your screen once both
fighters have announced who they're
going to be fighting for that's what
we're gonna put the question up because
we don't want you guys voting before you
actually hear the arguments that would
be silly and then what you do is just
like go to the bottom hit the gear
annotations on and off and then you're
going to go and hit the iCard and that
is going to be where the drop down comes
for your polls and I will be reading
those out only in the case of a tie if
there is no tie then I'll just be
reading them out because Reading Is
Fundamental oh hell yeah
Daniel Radford don't get sent her corgis
and dank mean big means Accord is thank
you yeah so we are going to get this
movie fight started momentito but first
a word from Dan Merle yes how because
today we're very lucky we have a spot
where we're not only we back we have a
sponsor today yeah yeah it was brought
to you by blue apron YUM how it's been a
busy couple weeks we've been chair
shopping we we've been doing so many
things
now you don't have time to go to the
grocery store which is why I was lucky
that blue apron came and said you want
us to sponsor the show I said yes they
sent us a box if you subscribe to blue
apron you get a box right at your door
you don't have to go shopping it's
refrigerated so it's not gonna spoil
it's like farm-fresh stuff but you know
what they cool it so if you unless you
don't check your mail for three days
don't do that no refrigeration system is
that you have to check your mail if you
subscribe to blue apron yeah you're
gonna get all the ingredients you're
gonna it's the right proportions you're
not gonna have stuff left over you have
to reheat stuff it's perfect you cook it
here's how good it is they sent me two
meals and I was supposed to keep one to
show on the show but I took them both
home and I ate them you're gonna have to
trust cuz I got ginger pork burgers
which is great we got we got spicy
pepper and onion quesadillas which is
great but here's what we did we enjoyed
them both separately and then we did a
remix and we combined them and we had
pork quesadillas also and it was very
good good so no commitment you can like
subscribe a week and then if you want to
have a cheat week you can even skip a
week and then just get back right back
in the next week it's not like you have
to get one every week for two months and
if you're watching there's a link down
there in the description below if you're
one of the first 50 people to sign up at
that link you're gonna get 40 bucks off
your first two weeks I'm so impressed
food it's delicious you're not gonna
have all the leftovers you don't have to
go shopping it's right to your door I
enjoyed it and I'm a picky guy I'm a
picky eater
yes damn rural but I can tell you
nici damn it's great yeah I've been
annoyed number for it so I had it was
like this crispy Korean pork with like
those awesome like rice cakes that are
like a little bit chewy and have like
bok choy and like ginger and like a soy
glass dude it was good like bok choy is
the most pretentious of all the choice
crunchy soy is Roy Choi not hungry man
dinners this is good stuffs awesome blue
apron check out the link sign up you're
gonna get $40 off your first two years
if you hurry and do it right now nice
you know so check it out awesome sounds
super delicious can't beat that deal
with an egg whisk eggs all right so
let's get into the good times so we have
three regular rounds so three full
rounds are going to be followed by a
four questions speed round in the event
that we're tied after the three rounds
because we got the three players don't
worry and we got to cover we got a
little tiebreaker action that will
happen to solve that issue that ethical
challenge is the physical challenge
where you down the ground and leg
wrestle and as I mentioned earlier there
are three judges myself Dan and Danielle
Radford who is the conduit who you will
be speaking through the voice of the
YouTube poll everybody got that you
feeling it yeah yeah possessed by
YouTube got it JT II dropped that sick
ass package
[Music]
time
[Applause]
alright jte the best package in the biz
alright this question I think this first
question is actually like a real jinx
but uh explain that I say which current
director which current director is the
next Spielberg which current directors
in xfield burg I remember when Time
magazine called M night Shyamalan the
next put him on the cover and Annie went
on a big-ass losing streak but that
aside which current director do we think
is the next Spielberg and we're going to
stop start right here in chair number
one with josh mokuba I'm gonna go with
Ava Duvernay and uber nay it's it's it's
one of those last names you can spell
however you like
listen do Davern a duper night how do we
call it how are we saying it's Duvernay
right Duvernay Duvernay you two pull on
that fellow stank on people do ver a ver
Duvernay okay that was Josh's opening
argument she's great
listen I think ava duvernay is did I
seem wrinkle in time no Reese a bunch of
younger actress there's actresses that
maybe it success somewhere down the line
but ava duvernay has really mean listen
she's she's coming in hot with a DC
franchise she's got a what sounds like a
Spielberg s kind of project the battle
for Versailles which is like a runway
show these are all in pre-production of
runway show of like French designers
versus American designers and there
aren't many people that can go into the
documentary world and get nominated for
an Oscar and the live-action and or
scripted whatever narrative and also
deserve to be nominated for Oscars and a
lot of the work that she's done add on
top of that she directed a music video
for jay-z and Beyonce and if you're
gonna direct those two you can do just
about anything that's my argument ava
duvernay alright thank you
mokuba's Joestar I always appreciate
Josh being the kid doing a Booker for
based on the cover I went with Paul King
he's the director of the delightful
Paddington and its sequel the aptly
named Paddington too he also directed a
comedy series called the mighty boosh
which was delightful I went into this
thinking like the question isn't who's
the better director it's specifically
like who's who's an XP leg and I think
that's a very specific thing Spielberg
is ordinary characters and extraordinary
circumstances it's it's that sort of
childlike sense of wonder loss of
innocence and then it's just you know
fun adventure and I think what Paul King
did in the Paddington movies really
accentuates all of those and and and
explores them really well and really
knocks that out of the park it's a
simple there they're both deceptively
simple movies which I think Spielberg is
his his themes are complex and and
there's a lot of ideas but how he
presents things to you is is is fairly
simple and straightforward which I think
Paddington did Spielberg has this huge
very specific visual style I think Paul
King does as well and so I think of the
of the three one of which we will be
revealed in a moment
I think Paul King is the most in line to
be the next few Berg thanks Joe Star ed
Grier as usual for me it's hard for me
to talk about my entry without attacking
the other entries I have to muzzle
myself for this first round i'm dmx in a
90's video right now i'm barking very
tiny it's called a reference all right
this is the thing my criteria for what
is spielberg in in these directors is
your first you make money your movies
make money period
that's Spielberg Ian number two your
movies are they go in a pattern like
small movie like dual weird attachment
to a certain sort of weird small genre
movie like
and express and then your big fat hit
your big fat hit that just put your
wiener on the table and to me Ryan
Coogler has done that he did Fruitvale
station he made a subway shooting
marketable okay then he did Creed which
was a feel-good for everybody got
everybody on board no no political stuff
just everybody get with the punchin and
then knock this all out with a billion
dollar sci-fi movie release that that is
unprecedented much like jaws was for its
time
so my man by the criteria that I've set
up which are the best criteria not this
childlike Wonder crap and this know
pronounce that are named garbage this my
friend is the criteria and it is a
little little little big movie slightly
bigger big movie and then huge big fat
hit Ryan Coogler is the next Bill burr
BAM all right a lot of fighting words
from Ed Grier right there gentlemen
fight it out I mean Josh hasn't seen any
of these films Black Panther and I saw
Creed Cougars name person hence the
reason why it would
the next generation okay did you think
that a time could get wrinkled you
didn't know but then she came in and
wrinkled the living out of it that was
completely meaningless how much I don't
know what to do with you on a daily
basis hey you want to talk about Pocky
you know what I would like to try to
talk about Paul King but I can't even
take it seriously in this conversation
which means it's really laughable I mean
Paul Cain Paddington Paddington - but
does that make you a Spielberg ndu
Marlin marmalade Muppets does not a
Spielberg make an alliteration does not
a master camera look I think I think his
work is very earnest and kind it doesn't
weak it wink at the camera and I think
if you can master that kind of
storytelling without dipping into
cynicism or crassness like Spielberg
hands that's so much easier that's so
much harder to master then then say
spectacle and even a lot of drama and
sort of like Oscar prestige film that's
it's so hard to find that balance of
just right down the center of just
wholesomeness and earnestness but with
the real feeling of stakes and
attachment okay how do you walk around
with all that hip nasaan your back like
you're just so hip you get everybody's
first album and your bootlegs are better
than my albums I don't have hips that's
a hip that's a really hip choice but
it's not serious to me I feel like I
feel like if you're gonna be the next
Spielberg I shouldn't have to look up
your IMDB credits and then still be
wondering what those credits if you want
to talk about you directly go merci
shark or was that the other guy
established directors can't be the next
bill berg they're already themselves I'm
sorry like none of these people have
like massive IMDB not establish the next
DMX but yet I could still be the next
DMX if X comes out again it's just us
are can stop paying your taxes
I think koogler I think koogler
is his own thing and I I think if this
was a who is the best new director
conversation oh god its Ryan Coogler
it's Ryan Coogler for probably the next
20-30 years who is honestly that's kind
of my point though it's the fact that no
one I don't think anybody took it
seriously that he would he could be in a
Spielberg Ian category of you can just
hand him any sort of material and have
him put a but like he's a good spin on
it a nice even vision a nice commercial
but that was a free lunch isn't is an
exclusive to Spielberg spikes Spike
Jonze did that a lot of people have
already done that sort of Spike Jonze
draws him here's the thing though okay
Spielberg has dabbled in both right
narrative and documentary so is ava
duvernay okay it makes a pretty
Spielberg a reach and a wrinkle in time
I mean Paul King has dabbled in
television just like Stephen King did
I've even King Steven Spielberg
I think even their beginnings are
similar in that Ryan Coogler God is Indy
and then they like cranked him up the
mountain he's even said in interviews
he's like I haven't really even had time
to figure out like what the Ryan Coogler
style is because now I'm just in it and
I've had to hit the ground running
whereas Steven Spielberg like Paul King
has had time to sort of quietly develop
with short films and with television
projects made-for-tv movies before he's
made his step but much like much like
Kugler though spielberg always put
himself in the deep end he went from
doing you know Alfred yeah of Alfred
Hitchcock episodes to to even dual that
was a huge step Alfred Hitchcock episode
to put the camera over there put the
camera over there do all he was having
to like have you know mount cameras do
all kind of mad Mac stuff so I feel as
though Kugler has been thrown in the
deep end for a froot realization he got
thrown in the deep end of doing heavy
genre the legacy picture with the second
movie you know on a young director was
didn't think he could even do it for
Kugler wasn't the the format already
there for him to just
insert fun stuff for Marvel for Marvel
and for Creed like Creed it
he's Apollo's son he fights there's a
fight and things happen like there's not
a lesson Fruitvale station great movie
the other two are cookie cutter
I love Black Panther and it was probably
the best Marvel movie and ever maybe but
it's already there it's already in place
it's not like a DC EU or there like we
don't know the tone we don't know
whatever they're like okay mechanism for
oh we're gonna put this in a billion
theaters the first movie to be put in a
billion theaters that's to me worth
being part of the Marvel brand if we're
gonna talk about somebody of similar
skill set and a big hit coming out of it
I think it's half a dozen one to six to
the other if you're counting the Marvel
brand versus them giving him a
best-selling book Spielberg had a
best-selling book to work off of and the
first wide release ever in over a
thousand theater release ever so that to
me is commensurate with having the
Marvel brand they still did a great
bang-up job on their third picture but I
think goes with my paradigm hits and box
offices I think where the comparison
stops if I think if you want you know a
more full picture you've got to look at
you know style and feel that's what I
think about when I think of spielberg
like there's a reason why things like
what when you see a nostalgia projects
there's spielberg references stranger
things super 8 and i think paul king TV
queen sugar no but to certain people
spielberg has a cookie cutter style
because I mean so Spielberg to me is
Scorsese with a good childhood if we're
talking about real vision do you think
Euler married an actress allocate
CAPTCHA on Temple of Doom the movie
would be better than Temple of Doom or
the same as Temple of Doom if he had to
force his then wife his wife force
herself into a movie let me ask you this
which which aunjanue in the indiana
jones trilogy what each of our directors
probably marry I think Kugler would go
for Willie Scott and I think that's
that's bad taste on Googlers you know
like I think you go for a make a let's
move to find final thoughts
Josh McKoon uh guys listen okay there's
a time to make movies and then there's a
reasonable time
thank you
I think there's such a strong feeling of
all the elements that make a Spielberg
film Spielberg plus his own spin in Paul
King's work from just family that
feeling of timelessness nostalgia that
childlike sense of wonder that he fits
into his films while still having his
own distinct style just like Steven
Spielberg does that's why when I say who
who could be the next Steven Spielberg I
look at a guy like that I'm like this
guy if he can if he can nail family film
the same way that Steven Spielberg was
able to nail et then that means he can
nail his his his Jurassic Park he can
nail his War of the Worlds he can nail
those other pieces of subject matter
because he took the most challenging
thing which is I think a family movie
that's respectful and challenging to all
of its audiences and and hit it on the
head just like king did with Paddington
Thank You Edie final thoughts um III do
reject the notion that it's oh well
grand Cougars his own thing we're
talking about Pete everybody every one
of these directors are their own thing
so let's throw that out every one of
these directors has their own thing
we're talking about somebody that has
the ability to have the box office
staying power and the populist sort of
vision that just over and over again
works works works and look at Kugler
over and over again his cookie cutter
vision much like Spielberg's cookie
cutter beautifully they're beautiful
cookies you know nobody's in they're not
beautiful cookies but all I'm saying is
he is that guy he is that commercial
juggernaut who uses a slight outsider's
view to apply to all the genre
filmmaking and elevated he is that guy
and he will have Jurassic park's in his
future time Wow okay guys what a battle
welcome back fellas you know what the
trailers bring this yeah that's what
they bring okay so right out of the gate
right out of the gate Josh when you said
that you didn't see wrinkle of time you
know what I was like okay you got an
uphill battle and yet never recovered
from
oh man will own suicides why he left her
Louie Brad I love I love it and I love
that you bring up 13th and other you
know her body of work but yeah just
having not seen the film that put it
between Jo and Edie and Edie your
opening salvo had me I was like it is
Edie
it is Edie all day long but I feel like
they got a couple of dings on you and
there that you really didn't address as
far as the the structure being in place
as far as like the Creed and the Marvel
Universe and I think those were points
you could have defended I was waiting
for more because yours is the choice
that I would have chosen I love your
choice but at the end of the day I felt
like I just heard more about the
directors style and just more specifics
in regards to the sense of childlike
wonder and setting it up so even though
at face value I totally disagree with
what I'm about to say and I love your
choice Edie I gotta go Joe star for the
arguments so that's one for Joe on this
one I just surprised myself with that
choice Dan Merle I feel like I got a
fact the check these facts before I give
my judgment yes sir he's ahead several
first of all I have to fact-check you oh
I hate to do it but Newsweek was the
magazine they called a nice job on the
next Spielberg not Time magazine I would
also like to note for those watching at
home we don't assign our fighters their
answers but cuca just picked Ava
Duvernay and failed to prepare of his
own volition
true story I don't know it's a new world
challenge certainly set yourself a
challenge a bravura all three of these a
manoeuvre nice directing new gods for DC
the Battle of Versailles movies for HBO
Paul King is attached to a currently
untitled Willy Wonka project Ryan
Coogler is teaming with Michael B Jordan
again next for a movie called wrong
answer
with a screenplay by Tennessee Coates so
they all have new projects in
development Paddington was CGI not a
muppet
Steven Spielberg directed episodes of
Night Gallery not Alfred Hitchcock
Presents although he did sneak on to an
Alfred Hitchcock set and got thrown off
sneak under studio lights back in the
70s and jaws did not open on over a
thousand screens it approached that
number in August it did have an
unusually wide release but not a
thousand screens around that having said
all that nicely done on the
fact-checking she's having said all that
yeah it's between Jo dead but for me I
think
EDI Jo's certainly sold me on the
optimism and the freshness of his choice
but I think Edie sold for me the career
parallels the fact that he has kind of
navigated similar waters and had the
future and what has already come versus
what's what's ahead he sold me on Kugler
so I am actually going to side with Edie
we're locked up at 1-1 let's go to
Danielle Radford to bring it home with
the fam Danielle you know you're a big
Josh McKoon this one isn't me this is
all the people and the people to love
you we'll look into the memes in a
second but it was a very very strong
Ryan kube's at 68% Paul King at 26
eight-foot Savard a at 5% sorry Josh and
Ava
so some honorable mentions from folks
both in the chat and around Chris no one
got loved Matt Reeves got love Jordan
Peele got some love there were some
great statuses at
at underscore mrs. Davis said I've read
a lot of essays that sound like Josh's
argument energy but it's great isn't
going to be good artists reward said
wieners on the table is the important
takeaway from this round hashtag hashtag
it at Red Raider 3 well we've already
gone off the rails Josh Justin making
loud noises and that's awesome and let's
see I had one more that I really liked
that was just our lungs sorry guys I had
to pick lungs good I thought this was
really funny
bold choice to pick a co-director with
whom he's unfamiliar with cotton let's
see if this works out Danielle thank you
for holding it down over there so ed
Grier charges into the lead in his one
zero after one around nicely done ed
I'll never forgive you okay you know
you're speaking of senors spielberg Oh a
ready player one is opening up it is
open so if the Oasis were real what
character would you want to play as if
the Oasis were real what character would
you want to play as it's round number
two we're gonna start with player number
two Joe star ready player two guys in
the world of the Oasis a world of fun
references and characters and I know
that thing which is also a world where
all of these characters are just skins
you where they're just they're just
avatars you don't get their powers you
don't get their their personality or
their charm or their weaknesses
you just get their face there's only one
correct choice and that is circus season
five of full house Michelle tanner
because this is the Oasis is built on
hayai sic reference I know you and
everyone is gonna remember Michelle
tanner in the Oasis everyone's gonna
remember this five-year-old girl that's
got a jetpack or machine guns are bought
or bought Akira's motor
cycle or whatever and is zipping around
saying you got it dude before they
teabag on people after shooting them
like in halo everyone's gonna want
Michelle Tanner in their clans or their
or their posses or whatever you call it
in video games it's the most memorable
person everyone's always gonna be all
across the room Michelle tanner and it's
like oh and I bought Captain Hook's
eyepatch from the store and now I'm
pirate Michelle tanner Michelle tanner
BAM okay whoo Michelle tanner
teabagging is he banging people in the
Oasis at Grier putting her Weiner on the
table
oh speaking of which I would never
choose that because I don't want pedos
freaking on me and the Oasis I mean
you're right people would roll up on you
with a lot of weird agendas so no my
pick is the Silver Surfer
I think you see a guy he's the Silver
Surfer he's reflective and whatever
little whatever manna or whatever you
get in the games and stuff I would apply
it to my surfboard so I could surf
around on my surfboard I could fly
around I can do approximations of his
powers for our fictional world so you
know I got energy blasts I'm surfing I'm
invulnerable in space I can go to like
some oasis version of space I'm a
surfboard
I just think there's a qualitative
difference between if you want to be an
avatar like Superman or an avatar like
Silver Surfer
there's a qualitative difference in the
reaction like you said we call it an
inferred direction to the reference but
I think Silver Surfer garner so I pick
Silver Surfer great Silver Surfer
awesome Josh McKoon
what do you got Eva do burn
[Applause]
into the Oasis they're nothing like good
old Ava okay my my character here in the
Oasis is Mega Man classic Nintendo
started in the Capcom Nintendo era Mega
Man 2 on Gameboy might be the greatest
Gameboy game in the history you go into
the Oasis you want a hat I mean listen
he's got a plasma cannon anybody he
beats he already gets their power so
he's used to getting other powers also
you wouldn't think a little guy like
that could jump but that guy can jump he
can jump all over the place he kind of
looks like he deserves to be in the
Oasis cuz his outfit already fits what
do you think he's futuristic no you just
say oh that's Mega Man he's a sweet
little guy but also kind of a big ass
dude he has both like he can really
morph into just about anything there are
so many versions of Mega Man that you
can get because there are so many bad
guys that he beats number one electro
dude which come on this is I mean
electro man I would say electro do but
electro man he can shoot listen mega
make and shoot and take on just about
anything
and his name is Mega Man III don't know
I can you beat a net you've got Megatron
you've got mega mind I've got everything
but Mega Man well I mean your name would
be like Makua dude 69 and he would look
like Mega Man yeah but look if you want
to talk about like cool custom arms with
weapons Michelle tanner can also have
those weapons so give her cut man's
rolling cutter she'll look awesome
that rolling cutter was sick that
rolling cutter was sick but now you give
Michelle tanner she's like let's roll
Danny oh and then she's throwing
scissors at people that's cool
here's my issue with your characters the
Oasis is seems like it's mostly blue
black and silver anyway so people are
gonna have a hard time really seeing you
- you're not gonna stand out well
against the all silver and blue
background that seems to be the Oasis
where visually Michelle Tanner will
stand out in a crowd I'm so confused as
to where Michelle Tanner
fits in the pantheon of people that
would strike fear in the hearts of China
about striking fear it's about
recognizing a reference and based on the
numbers of fuller house people are gonna
recognize Michelle Tanner people love
she's not even in for house she's in
full no but the people that watch fuller
house are there because they
full house they they love both Olsen
twins playing one little girl here's the
I don't think Silver Surfer it's a good
reference I think people are going to be
confused that you're running around
cosplaying as the second place Oscar
like also have a cool surfboard and zip
around wait there's Michelle Tanner get
all of these special powers and why are
we trusting a five year old girl who
could only really say you got it dude
but you're not using a five year old
girl you're just trusting a cool-looking
carrot of big ridiculous I pointed out
that my character can also be the t1000
I mean there's a lot of stuff I can do
it been a super body I could be a
mannequin from a rap video would be a
lot of taken surfer language Bo totally
ripped it and you've already abandoned
the silver surfer and that disappoints
me part of my partner's of a service
powerset is to fly around on a surfboard
and do a lot of transmuted of things
with the cup with the power cosmic is
actions that you look up that is John
dan what does that mean there's a lot of
things that I could do to make different
references and if the Silver Surfer got
out of out of Knight Rider or something
like that that because like a where's
your surfboard dude there's a lot of
stuff that can happen is your one note
if they don't like this particular
sitcom that's a one note it's something
that Ernest Cline our and then the
character of whatever the dude the guy
in the Oasis come on help me up Walsh
yeah Brandon Walsh I know to us what is
silver surfers power what does he do
he's got the practice you guys used the
first couple seasons then by season five
she was just kind of ruining people's
days every episode was like shell
doing two noobs in the Oasis is ruining
their days and saying you got it dude
and then getting back in the gun star
from The Last Starfighter in the whole
Sun mega man comes in he's just like
blaster can apparently my guy is main
cultural icons oofy child and then a
handless cannon we haven't heard any
other takedowns of Mega Man anyone
created and held on to a franchise for
years so I'm for your final thoughts for
your final argument I want you to take
us through an adventure in the Oasis
with your character keep it brief keep
it concentrated and concise but take us
on a short little journey with your
chosen avatar in the Oasis we're gonna
start with Joestar okay Michelle Tanner
and her little her little gaming clan a
Velociraptor from Jurassic Park and the
NFL Pro Stars they're gonna go right
another clan and they're all like you
guys ready to go and Michelle Tanner's
like they're in big trouble mister and
she she puts the rolling cutter on that
she got from Mega Man after she beat his
ass earlier in a game day of gaming they
raid this other clan and then everyone's
like that's brilliant because the
Internet's in it for the lulz Thank You
Joestar Edie take us on your little
adventure I say we go we go hunting for
Michelle tanner man the crew like it's
like Silver Surfer and but I just have a
bunch of silver dudes Silver Surfer
silver sable silver Saint silver st.
cloud Joel silver you talk about deep
cut references silver st. cloud from
Batman yeah we all we all know the
silver gang
so the silver clan goes hunting for
Michelle Tanner and I use my energy
power to turn into an energy-based
version of our coal and I beat you up
and that's amusing for certain people
who watch those that set of shows and
then after we do that we kind of we surf
I get the surfboard out and me in the
clan go surfing with a Brody and and
Johnny Utah from a Point Break with the
clan well you know we got black hoods
from the thank you sir
josh mokuba all right here we go druids
coax okay Megaman all his his enemies in
the Mega Man franchise he's convinced to
come with him so now he's got all these
other mega men he's also got the rest of
the Tanner family who consistently hate
Michelle because she ruins everything
out scream oops did I do it again
whatever her other countries were sorry
that was Britney Spears my back and then
clearly obviously on the team with them
is a animatronic full of lasers t1000
Ava Duvernay and what happens is there
is a medal that they have to find and
get but the only way to get that is what
the certain powers megaman is able to
bring out in every single character
because once Megaman touches them he can
give them powers
that's the Megaman way blaster cannon
cut man electro man danny tanner's clean
man Jesse's guitar man Joey's Popeye man
stephanie is wreck the car in that
episode of the red card of the episode
man DJ Tanner is date Steve man Aunt
Becky is wake up San Francisco man
they've got all of these different
powers and then clearly Ava Duvernay
is wrinkle man with all of these powers
led by Mega Man they get the medal they
save the Oasis Liam Gallagher comes in
Wonderwall BAM Josh thank you for that
borderline gibberish
shut it down all right let's go to Dan
Morel to fact-check and give us his
thoughts first very little factual basis
and those arguments about a few things
yeah II like man what's the name of the
Mega Man character look man they ran out
of character Silver Surfer has the power
cosmic which does include transmutation
meaning that you can change or alter the
form of anything so the head was correct
in those powers they're Mega Man what's
created not by Mega Man he was created
by Akira keep Tamura in 1987 but her
nickname is certain social circles or
his nickname like a mega me all right no
big deal so actually to clean up there
mm-hmm
everything else was a bit messy you know
strangely it is about joining the group
you know the Oasis is much about finding
your team and finding your force I think
is about individual play and all of you
kind of presented your scenarios there
and I have to say the one that I thought
sounded most effective was mccoggins one
oh yeah this was this was a toughy for
me cuz you're really like I mean just
there's a lot of goofiness and but there
was a I mean there was a lot of cool
crap I mean I love like pirate Michelle
tanner and the boss right yeah no boss
and
but then I'm also like ed like knocked
you down with that like oh you're gonna
have like a lot of weirdos creeping on
you and that's like a little addled act
without weirded me out that like made me
like oh what I want to pick Michelle
tanner I have the pro starts watching my
back okay yeah they're burly dudes and
one out with a little girl that's great
yeah Josh you're having fun so like and
that's infectious I love fun I love Ava
I love they can ride Ava back I mean I
feel like Ed sold me with that last
group of all the silvers the silver clan
and then him using his transmutate of
powers to become another 80/90 s icon
Arkell and shut down Michelle tanner and
as merkel whoa that was a like that's a
beautiful picture in my bag so then I'm
going that Grier on this one let's go to
Danielle it was a cold day today on
screen junkies you got to mention Urkel
twice alright well going and mother
overwhelming the chat has spoken in the
chat voted for Michelle tanner
51% mega-mega 32% in the Silver Surfer
at 16%
we have to break out the tiebreaker for
this for this round all right Billy's
coming yeah Billy this is called
learning on your feet we can get the
opportunity it's gonna be Molly right
now not having to have an opinion yet um
I I absolutely positively have to go
with mega men on this one yes I
understand but it was just I feel like
he really did embrace the you all
embraced the silliness but I feel like
Josh was just like he dived all the way
in and that is what this question
demands so yeah I gotta go with Megaman
BAM mokuba gets them we are one Josh one
Joe zero going into question number
three do you mind cuz the guys are
really one my memes Oh
memes on we had some some Zeno of people
had Daria a lot of people saying MEAP in
the chat MEAP too old I don't know what
that means me poor me me no idea
a bunch of people talking about dr.
Manhattan and wondering why there was no
love for stuff Tanner no yeah yes you
wrecked
uncle Jesse's car yeah out of the house
yeah with the DeLorean what a battle you
guys let's go to question number three
what Disneyland slash Disney World
attraction would make the worst movie
attraction is euro or Tokyo Disney
factor into this never mind what
Disneyland or Disney World attraction
would make the worst movie and we're
gonna start with my man ed Grier on the
end
Edie okay now I'd like to establish what
I think we should all those gentlemen
agree are the rules because
I'm using part of my time to do this
because a lot of times on this show
people go love to see that and they
don't mean it you started you start
pitching some garbage so they're good to
see that sir no you know you'd hate to
see this movie and this movie is the
Matterhorn right yes it's got a Yeti but
boy I can make the Yeti really boring I
know a way to do it
and bobsledding is already boring and
it's a one directional like it's a real
commitment vehicle like you and somebody
are committed to do anything if you're
in a bobsled so that's real boring Oh
buddy there's a bunch of boring stuff
about the Matterhorn man if you watch
the movie about the Matterhorn you'd be
super bored and you'd have to be trapped
in the room watching that for two hours
so I'm just let it later let it lie baby
BAM Matterhorn bobsleds from Ed Greer
josh mokuba coming around to you
this gonna be real quick yeah it's a
small world Thank You Joestar you'll
want to be that quick I can't I have ten
words yes keep going
soundtrack your kids already sing frozen
Moana you want to go around the house
saying it's a small world after all over
and over again
that's how parents lose their minds Joe
all right Thank You Josh McKoon we'll
come back to you for more Joestar you
know to counter ad I can also think of a
really cool Matterhorn movie it's a the
it's it's cliffhanger meets Cool
Runnings they crash into the mountain
and the cast of Cool Runnings has to
escape it yet Ian's right let's get
counter-arguments in a moment let's have
your answer please you know just
mirroring these opening arguments you
know if I have to mic drop a name it's
Disney's the Indian village Disney the
the best company with the most spotless
track record with Native Americans doing
a movie based on the Indian village
mm-hmm that's all I got
okay might be problematic let's fight it
out Jake
I know how to fix the Indian of the
Indian village movie you make it no you
don't make now nope because now it is a
Bollywood extravaganza we got 500
million dollars from India to press it
yeah no it's not anything more it's
actual Indian real Indian people and it
would take all the all the cultural
sensitivity out of it we make so much
money and there's a huge audience and
you don't you take that Native American
stigma off of it I also think the fix
for it's a small world the song being
terrible is I think that's the first
thing Disney's gonna be like we got
fixed that song and they're gonna make
some kind of like what are they gonna
make Hamilton wrap it yeah they're gonna
like absolutely yeah but listen it's a
small world he's got to come out with
his old rap improv group and they're
gonna beatbox like college guys do and
they're gonna do your head like a worm
crawling through your brain yeah it is
the way and all but what you're gonna do
all those kid voiceovers of all those
little things like this moment what is
that movie it's creepy it goes from land
to land to land
yeah that's offensively small peanut
mayor Mitchell it is children learning a
lesson about unity in the same way that
I think the wizard is Rain Man for kids
this could be a rival for kids kids
learning to come together guys it would
not have to be that boring it could be
like that weird Torchwood episode of us
that we're Church wepa sowed where my
aliens come to take the world's children
and they all unite and point in the sky
and say say a certain phrase it's a
small world after all so the aliens have
taken over all of our kids and now
they're pointing at the sky waiting for
our Harbor Jets
yeah I just made it a better movie huh
huh here from the from the from the box
I'm still I'm still from the company
that gave you the song what makes the
red man red and Johnny Depp playing
Tonto here's a movie about white people
walking around just looking at Indians
yes
wander among teepees of the Indians
Iroquois birchbark longhouses cedar
planked houses meet a full-blooded
Indian chief and then climb aboard an
Indian war canoe it's the worst ride
from Disney there's no way there's no
way that a company who historically like
you guys can say the most offensive
movie but it's not the worst you can
actually get will be you could make a
movie about Native Americans you don't
have to call it the Indian but Disney
Disney has proven time and time again
that they rule they can they can make an
interesting premise I have a small world
and they could make a very cool
Matterhorn movie I really think that my
Matterhorn movie because you guys are
talking about this ridiculous stuff
break it down my Matterhorn movie is
okay there's two kids all right no
there's a married couple there's a
married couple who's stranded on the top
of a mountain now yeah yeah of course
yeah so there's a married couple and
they're stranded on top of a mountain
and they have to get down and they have
to like basically build a bobsled
together and it's like part of them
saving their marriage 40 minutes of a
married couple trying to save their
marriage by building a bobsled hold on
and then so they give the bobsled
together and they don't even want to get
into it cuz they don't want to commit to
that and that's like that's almost third
act okay then they get in the bobsled
they go over a really bunny hill type
thing and it really wasn't a big deal
for them to get to the bottom but then
they get attacked by a Yeti
but then the Yeti explains to them that
he was actually their marriage counselor
the whole time and all the adventures no
no no cuz for the last
I feel like I got a good picture of that
go ahead and just break down what your
movie looks like quickly well the movie
would be terrible you have kids living
in other places where are their parents
why are they always singing it's not
listen Disneyland a Disney World are not
the happiest places on earth and the
least happy place in all of those is
it's a small world you get in there the
song gets in your head
their parents regret even taking their
kids there because then the kids get
confidence that they can actually be in
a time I'm gonna call it right there
okay wow what a battle what an epic
smackdown so hold hold that thought so
um and you start us start us off and
yeah you had me I was like oh yeah it
could be super boring bobsledding what a
snoozefest but then i was like in my
head I was like Cool Runnings we can
bring that up and I'm like oh could be
interesting but no youyou sold me on the
snooze fest but then the movie you
described sounded pretty good like a
married couple stranded on top of a
mountain like live live meets Cool
Runnings and yet fro no that's that's my
fantasy so I feel like you took yourself
out of the Cool Runnings I'm describing
a pretty good movie and Josh Josh I like
loved the fact like your opening salvo
of like your thing would drive parents
crazy I was just hearing it over and
over just evil little children going
around singing it's a small world then
like you got rebutted a little bit about
like they may be the remake to the song
and everything and then when we ask you
to describe a movie you just went back
to describing the ride and you didn't
really describe a movie you broke down
the just how problematic you helped him
by saying he would have the most
offensive movie which by some people's
definition would be the worst movie and
when you walked us through what your
movie would look like paralleled with
the Indian village experience you sold
me on at my point goes to Joestar dan
murrelets well my job is judged based on
the facts yes sir
you know just the backstay in just
effects looking at the facts matterhorn
it's a small world
open Indian village was closed in 1971
mmm so I have to kind of take that into
into into my brain a little bit yes I'm
here to judge factually when it's a
curly open attraction what's up it's a
currently open attraction where we did
know we did oh I know but I'm saying
it's my job to judge based on the facts
sure
we finally got around to being sensitive
about the Native American plight in 1917
I don't know I feel like I feel like I
don't think everyone was on an even
playing field here so I have to what is
the worst movie of these movies I don't
I don't feel like either Joe or or
makuta really described a movie they
just both described how terrible their
own attractions were which could so by
default I think I have to go for ed
because II D at least described why this
movie would be the worst and I think
John McDougall were just like I picked a
terrible attraction that's half the
question but the other half is which
one's gonna make the worst movie so I
think by default I have to side with ed
one for Joe one for Edie
Danielle bring it home please okay let's
look at the voice the people as of right
now we've got Indian village at 65% it's
a small world of 29% and Matterhorn
bobsleds so yeah Indian village not two
not so strong I will say my favorite of
the things I saw on Twitter was at David
pockets 90 says round three Disney
presents turkey leg stand the movie oh
I'd go see that Billy was that not my
second answer yeah my second hand is
Turkey like them all right
that's them I love turkey legs you guys
we're all tied up at 1 1 1 all hell is
breaking loose but we got ourselves a
tiebreaker
here's how this works okay they are each
going to pick something out of this hat
it's a category and they will have each
have 20 seconds 20 seconds on the clock
to name as many criteria as sorry as
many bullet points within that category
Azamat name as many things in that
category as they can whoever has the
lowest number is eliminated okay
so they each have different category
each of 20 seconds to name crap
whoever has whoever has the lowest
number of things named within their
category bye-bye
alright go ahead and pick one don't say
one at a time
got it great great great oh yes thank
you for that that was important
all right great okay yeah 20 seconds on
the clock I have the clock we have 20
seconds on a kick my category is sports
movies as soon as I start talking is
that when the clock goes as soon as you
name the first movie the clock will
start okay Hoosiers Mighty Ducks Mighty
Ducks 2d3 tin cup Longest Yard Remember
the Titans glory road the natural Field
of Dreams the rookie for the love of the
game
speed no that's not a son of a karateka
Days of Thunder wow that's great I think
NASCAR counts I put a NASCAR 1213 mean
Guga 13 for mokuba solid Joestar what do
you got I've got this one
movies at speech feature spies movies
that feature spies alright 20 seconds
begins whenever you start talking the
man who knew too little the man who knew
too much
rollerball oh man all the James Bond the
world is not enough Tomorrow Never Dies
Goldeneye Skyfall atomic blonde John
wick Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy move on
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten are we counting John wick I had nine
because I don't know if rollerball
rollerball count as a oh no I'm not
coming to say Thunderball no no or not
no okay
it's not equal spy yup assassins is not
equal spies thank you for that pearl of
wisdom Dan Moreau okay ed Grier surprise
look at you assess and shoot at you what
do we got okay mine is movies that
feature aliens movies that feature
aliens 20 seconds start whatever you
talk gotta start Star Wars Empire
Strikes Back Return of the Jedi
alien aliens alien 3 Alien Resurrection
oh damn Oh a lien nation enemy mine not
chappy the other one district 980
you had to go to every mine
[Laughter]
and Josh in the sweet round everybody
well played everyone all right
welcome to the speed round now here's
how the speed round works the winner to
take home the today's movie fights
victory you need a total of four points
there are four questions in the speed
round the first person to talk gets to
go first you'll get 20 seconds 20
seconds and then you'll each get a 10
second rebuttal around 10 seconds 10
seconds and now Danielle will say
goodbye to the social media poll and she
will be judging her own self and it'll
be the three of us judging okay
so again first one to talk goes first
and 20 seconds 20 seconds 10 seconds 10
seconds gentlemen you feeling it feel it
ah what is this how about it all right
hugs first question of the speed round
in honor of today's movie fights what is
the best movie chair
Octopussy that's movie chair electric
chair and Green Mile okay I'll pick up
Professor Xavier hover chair all right
you spoke first 20 seconds begin
whenever you talk okay the movie The
Green Mile really does focus solely on
life in that prison and that electric
chair is the center of that movie there
is a extremely brutal scene where the
movie really kind of hits a climax when
that guy doesn't put the sponge on the
man's head and can you think of any
chair that has produced that kind of
vitriol within you than the electric
time Wow okay and whenever you're right
I think we're talking about the quality
of the chair
and I just don't think I'd want to sit
in a weird rickety old prison electric
chair like ever but homeboys hover chair
it goes upstairs you don't have to do
that with that weird gremlins pull you
up the stairs thing you got a Wits get
it's cool and hover technology is
obviously very gentle for the ground
ten-second rebuttals we all know that
hover technology is not possible people
have been faking us with the hoverboard
they're faking us with a heavy chair we
want realistic dynamics like the
electric chair I almost thought just for
craps and giggles I was gonna pick the
electric chair from the movie the
shocker but I didn't do that because
that's dumb because the hover chair
would be way better than any type of
electric chair all time all right let's
go to Danielle Radford we're essentially
looking at chair quality over the chairs
importance to a movie forgot this was
movie fights so for me I have to go wave
to Josh because I agree that that chair
is a very important part of the actual
plot of Green Mile and while obviously
Professor X's chair is really really
cool it's important part of his
character it doesn't play the key role
that Josh's chair played gotcha all
right Thank You Danielle that is one for
Josh let's go to Dan Murrow
I have also casting my vote for
substance over function and I enjoyed
the argument that the chair was not only
a chair but that it was an integral part
of the movie experience and I don't feel
that Edie really sold me that much on
the function and the key what would make
it better so I have to go also with
mokuba and the electric chair from the
Green Line BAM Kouga takes it wasn't
gonna win it on sheer importance
[Laughter]
thank you that question sponsored by
chair city chair city okay here we go
question number two question number two
oh all right
quest number two worst franchise to make
it to five or more movies what's the
worst franchise to make it to five or
more movies what is the Hobbit Lord of
the Rings together
no no Fast and the Furious Fast Eddie I
don't even know one besides Fast and the
Furious Five I'm gonna have to argue the
James Bond movies alright here we go
Josh you spoke first and you are going
first before the fast franchise okay
listen
recently the fast franchise has become a
decent but that can't make up for Tokyo
Drift too fast too furious at one point
they were just racing cars around with
no plot the actual the actual fact that
the Fast and Furious franchise has
gotten to this point and they are making
money blows the mind Tokyo and I believe
the most recent of the James Bond movies
have shown how a warmth in this premise
was it should have probably died in the
60s when you could actually engage in
espionage without satellites getting
involved and without a bunch of a
different media ruining the spy
experience but they chugged along for
years of years on that broccoli money
they didn't even make it off of movie
money it's just broccoli money funding
these movies
what is the fast in the franchise now
are they written car
are they spies are they international
assassins are they government employees
are they just people that work out and
punch each other I would also like to
argue that as far as worldwide gross and
and and the interest of involving all
peoples and all people loving these
movies fast and you can't even argue
that they're bad anymore they're like
almost empirically great by how much
money they make all the times party time
let's go to our minds I can said fast
and furious
I feel like Edie needed to expound more
on the second line of reasoning than his
first eye and the James Bond movies have
made a lot of money too so it's kind of
a wash for me something that's going
bakugans me to 100 cooks I actually have
to say I disagree I liked that he got
into the idea first of all the broccoli
thing that's something I wish was fact
checked but but I'm gonna go ahead and
believe it because I don't know any
better but I do like the idea that like
yeah it is the spy genre you know in
that particular vein should be changed
because of all the new tech um I'm gonna
go with that that's one one comes around
to me man I thought Cougs had it but
then Edie I felt landed devastating
knockout blows in that rebuttal round
with just how beloved it is bringing
people together and the gross of the
film so because of EDS rebuttal he took
that point for me it's to choose alright
who is okay number three who's the best
current member of the x-men cinematic
roster that means no Logan he dead who's
the best current member of the x-men
cinematic roster current member
you know I say great Jean Grae I say the
present Jean Grae Jean Grae so many of
them
what's the fast ones name Silver Streak
what was the thing you said just that
silver freak ok we heard ed with Jean
Grey first at 22nd starts when you speak
not only is that actress on the rise I
do believe so that would that would make
it viable for them to make movies about
her and include her in movies also her
character is being established as
somebody who's learning about her her
her second her excuse me uh telepathic
abilities and using them earlier and
better and they're going towards Phoenix
saga which if they do an actual cool
version of that that would be very
awesome
okay listen Quicksilver has probably the
most memorable scene in the reboot make
of what is now the x-men Cinematic
Universe when he kind of just push his
little bullets and plastic things and
punches people's faces there's you want
to see more of that guy's smart ass he's
funny he's fun he's basically the anti
Barry Allen in the most recent seasons
of the flash I like him he's quick I
would say that character is much like
the Hulk whereas they're very good in
small doses but to build an entire movie
or to include them in the larger fabric
of movie demand as like a big a deal be
Japan you can totally make a movie about
him that is probably better than what
the DC you would do with the flash and
don't brag on Hulk the dude is the man
you put both of those dudes together
that's a movie time and took that one
clearly for me
he had a great layout of potential
stories to explore and then a knockout
blow in the rebuttal that sent Josh
reeling trying to do damage control on
it
let's go to Dan it wasn't this clear-cut
for me I feel like I feel like Josh won
the pro argument but rules of debate
which I'm a debate nerd
I feel like Edie brought up cons that
Josh did not address when he had a
chance to and I felt like they were
strong enough that I'm gonna give the
overall argument to Ed cool story BAM
charges into the lead it is Edie threema
Cougs to career God oh wow and Makuta
needs this to tie it up if Edie takes
this he goes home Oh winner
all right here it is number 4 question
number 4 the speed around a new Pixar
short will be about a Chinese dumpling
that comes to life what inanimate object
should come to life in a future Pixar
short in out of an object what should
come to life in a future pixar short
burrito say that again a burrito a
burrito a cup a coffee cup a coffee cup
we have a burrito and a coffee cup
alright you spoke first Josh whenever
you're ready the burrito right now is
the great American food and I know that
it's not technically American as it is a
Mexican import but it has everything
that you could want inside of a food and
thus encapsulating an entire character
meats cheeses vegetables spices what
couldn't you do with an inanimate object
coming to life in the burrito
I think inherent in your burrito movie
it would just get eaten whereas my
coffee cup is not a styrofoam or
anything it is an actual like a mug or
something so it's the stories of the
different people that use the mug
throughout this company and all those
different stories taken from that Pixar
worm's-eye view of things through that
this cup powerbrokers it is nice to hear
about where this coffee mug may go but
we've already seen Anna
coffeeCup come to life in Beauty and the
Beast and he was kind of annoying
wouldn't you want to see what the
burrito can do the unraveling of life is
a tortilla and do we also get to see
them animate Oh like the maggots coming
out of it when somebody drops it on the
ground and it decays or going through
the gastrointestinal system is
ridiculous but my cup is walked and on
different people's desks okay Danielle
Radford I'm doing the bog one both
incredibly compelling arguments but I do
have to say I did again he gave us an
actual he gave us a movie and I am a
sucker for if you can have an idea of
what this might be and the idea of just
you know the different lives of the
people in one company is their mouth
touches this beard cup they'll wash it
in the company sink dan Murat works I am
very impressed by the kook is almost
philosophical duality a man opening with
what the ingredients in the burrito and
it's like the human nature and the what
what makes a man what they have to say I
think Edie really Pixar the crap out of
that maybe idea I mean the story of an
office says seen through the eyes of an
I saw that I saw that movie in my head
[Applause]
because it was touch-and-go thank you
congratulations man well fought well
played
deservedly so um go ahead and plug some
stuff Wow
I'm a caulking gun right now
nerd goat podcast obviously we talk to
interesting people like all the people
in this panel I'd love to have on their
show basically we take your your
favorite fictional character that your
nerd greatest of all time and we talk
about it for about an hour so it's a
real deep dive if you want to be deep if
it's just a bunch of riffs we can it be
a bunch of riffs but it's it's a pretty
good show five star rated and now we had
mark barnard and on recently we had a
guy Fernandez and if he and right away
I'm gonna have the Big Joe start on
pretty soon so yeah it's a great podcast
nerd podcast and I met great destroys on
social media of all types and I'm super
cool thank you and Joe star always
hilarious and a lot of good points and a
lot of weird points today go ahead and
tell us what's going on with you you
know you can spy me every day on sju
Monday through Fridays and I think this
is it this weekend Billy that it could
have been worse drops I have a video
dropping on Sunday on news new series
for trying cold it could have been worse
about the last Jedi I'm very excited
about it so watch it awesome thank you
sir Josh mokuba thank you for being here
thank you for talking out of your ass
from basically my life I mean it was
nice so much I come here to Toulouse I'm
currently one in seven in fights at this
place whether at Erie the time we get
listen I'm not exactly what you would
call a winner okay
obviously your ain't no as far as being
funny and delightful it could have been
worse well I you guys can follow me on
social medias at Josh mccoon uh my show
the Josh mahouka show on YouTube and
every week on WGN America I host a show
called WGN movies for America hell yeah
thank you sir
Dan Morelle yes thank you so much
anything anything coming up I I have
retired officially this week we're
talking about the last Jedi so I'm out
so I'm done with the last Jedi for now
but yeah we check out a bunch of stuff
and don't forget to check out the link
below for our blue apron deal
hell yeah thanks to them for sponsoring
the show and yeah I'm gonna go remix
more recipes I'm gonna nice could just
combine random foods - yeah your DJ blue
apron Daniel Radford thank you for
holding it down on the social media
please go ahead and plug some stuff firm
you can catch me on my weekly podcast
Heights and France where I talk about
wrestling comes out every Thursday also
again real great job Yeller doing a
follow me on the Instagram so I can get
some free fat girl clothes so if y'all
why just head over to Danielle
underscore Radford so I can get that
plus side sponsorship I would appreciate
it also the chat yes I do see all of
your thirst for Joe Joe they're real
thirsty for you at that chat right now
am i doing haha nice we're all thirsty
for more Joestar Thank You Danielle
Radford and I'm Hal Rudnick follow me at
how on the Twitter on the Instagram and
I want free stuff - I want skinny jus
guys beefy Italian dude doglike is there
something like please everyone send us
all free stuff I want to thank JT I want
to thank Billy biz and I want to thank
everybody who helped haul this big-ass
desk back in here thank you so much for
watching everybody see you next time on
hash tag movie fights live bye bye
you